hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast allosteric modulation of
meta Petrovic glutamate receptors for
the treatment of neurodevelopmental
disorders presented by colleen Icelander
professor of pharmacology director of
molecular pharmacology Vanderbilt Center
for Neuroscience drug discovery
I am Alexis Krause of leopard's and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots elaborates as the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this press presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the
accreditation button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen and follow the process to
obtain your credits please join me in
welcoming dr. an Icelander
I will now turn the presentation over to
her thank you very much Alexis I'm
really excited to be here today and to
share my work looking at allosteric
modulator xand I was going to present
this sort of as a as a case study of
practical use of allosteric modulator x'
in a target validation and drug
discovery campaign that we have ongoing
at the Vanderbilt Center for
Neuroscience drug discovery the Center
for Neuroscience drug discovery is a
group of scientists whose mission is to
promote the translation of advances in
basic science to novel therapeutics by
de-risking efforts that focus on novel
approaches for the treatment of brain
disorders which is something that many
pharmacy
companies in the recent past have shied
away from and so we feel that we really
have an easier to push neurological and
psychiatric disorders in an academic
setting and so the beast entity is
composed of groups of scientists that
focus on the disciplines of medicinal
chemistry and drug metabolism molecular
pharmacology high-throughput screening
and in vivo and translational
pharmacology here at the Beast and Edie
we do have all the major infrastructure
that you see for during discovery that's
traditionally found only in industry
settings we have about 75 full-time
employees in the VA CNTV
and we are home ground we are sort of a
biotech within the university our money
is soft money mainly from the NIH
foundations and pharmaceutical companies
and I'm excited to get to tell you about
one of our newest projects that we
started working on and that has to do
with allosteric modulator z' for the
treatment of neurodevelopmental
disorders and so what you're seeing on
this slide is the structure of a
metabotropic glutamate receptor it has a
large and terminal domain and then
transmembrane domains and these
receptors are constitutive dimers for in
thinking about ways to modulate GPCRs
you can either modulate a receptor by
interaction at the or the stearic side
so in the case of a tablet rip limit
receptor this would be the glutamate
binding site but this can be very
challenging to develop selectivity among
the different metabotropic glutamate
receptors which there are eight subtypes
and so we and others have looked for
compounds that interact with the
receptor at other sites and can modulate
the activity of glutamate so allosteric
means other allosteric ligands can be
positive in this case positive
allosteric modulator Zoar Pam's negative
negative allosteric modulator an AM or a
neutral these are called nails neutral
alastair blog and these are compounds
that can bind to the receptor but they
and they can block the binding of Pam's
and dams but they don't have any
efficacy of their own some of the
theoretical advantages at allosteric
modulator are
if a compound is a pure allosteric
modulator it will bind the receptor but
it won't do anything by itself and so
you have to have glutamate there in this
case in order for activity of the
modulator to be observed and so this can
help to maintain spatial and temporal
control of the signaling that would
normally be induced by the endogenous
against the effects of allosteric
ligands our saturable and this is
thought to be a feature that might
contribute to improved safety profiles
so they won't over activate for example
a receptor they saturate at a certain
level there are potential
pharmacokinetic advantages to allosteric
ligands for example for our work we need
compounds that obviously get into the
brain and many allosteric modulator czar
highly lipophilic and so they they have
better brain penetration profiles and
let's say something that might interact
at the or the stearic site which could
be like an amino acid which would be
charged as I mentioned one area of
advantage for Ellis are compounds for
GPC ours is that they can provide
improved selectivity for one receptor
versus other members in a family they
can induce signal bias and this is a
emerging area in pharmacology where
different modulator or different
agonists for example can induce signal
bias downstream of the receptor where a
modulator may not activate or potentiate
or block all pathways induced by the
agonist and this can be important in
thinking about maybe avoiding a pathway
that could give you a safety liability
so I'm going to transition now I'm going
to talk about our use of allosteric
modulator to interrogate specific
neurodevelopmental disorders I'm going
to start with a disorder called red
syndrome and red syndrome is a
particularly heartbreaking disorder
because when children are born we're
going to develop red syndrome and the
majority of the patients are girls
because it's an x-linked disorder
although there are boys who suffer from
red syndrome in the case of girls in
many cases the children are relatively
asymptomatic for about 6 to 18 months
then they undergo a very rapid
developmental regression and so they'll
lose many of the skills that they had
learned
they may stop talking they have gained
the ability to talk they stopped being
able to walk in many cases and then they
sort of reach a plateau phase after
about three years to adult and they may
have parkinsonian like movements but in
general they after the regression phase
they reach a phase of stability we know
that Rhett syndrome is caused by
mutations in the gene called methyl cpg
binding protein 2 or mechs ptoo then
this is a transcription factor it's
expressed on the X chromosome and
predominantly affects females as I
mentioned most of the time the mutation
develop spontaneously in spawn and since
boys don't get an X chromosome from
their father the majority of the cases
are female although as I mentioned there
are more and more boys are being
diagnosed with Rett syndrome in general
those boys do not survive very long some
of the hallmark characteristics the Rett
syndrome are abnormal breathing and this
can be periods of hyperventilation that
are followed by a Pia's and these can be
very disturbing for families and
caregivers because that the children or
young adults will appear stopped
breathing motor impairments as I
mentioned many that many of the patients
are wheelchair-bound
learning disabilities language deficits
and autistic features are all hallmarks
of the disorder seizures and when
seizures develop they can be very
difficult to treat and also once
something that's very characteristic of
Rett syndrome is actually a diagnostic
feature our hands-- terrianna piece
where the girls will sort of bring their
hands over and over and over again and
this prevents purposeful hand use so
they can't color they can't feed
themselves and this is very it's very
difficult for caregivers and families so
as I mentioned the majority of cases of
red syndrome which is actually a disease
that's diagnosed clinically and then
patients DNA sequence to find out where
the mutation would be the majority of
cases are caused by mutations in the MEC
T 2 gene and this is just a structural
diagram of BEC V 2 it has a methyl
binding domain shown in yellow a
transcriptional repression domain which
shown in
and the c-terminal domain and you can
see that the mutations usually found in
patients are often clustered in the
methyl binding domain and the
transcriptional regulation domain for
some time it was thought that the
predominant role of mek p2 is as a
transcriptional repressor so we're
pressing gene expression but
subsequently it's been identified that
MEC v2 can actually also be a
transcriptional activator depending on
the other cofactors that it complexes
with so it can have dual roles in terms
of gene expression
there are several mouse models of
resolume that are available for study in
the model that i'm going to tell you
about today exons 3 & 4 of the MEK p2
gene or excise this is the bird model of
Rett syndrome and this generates Menke
to knockout unveils and meki to
heterozygous females as in contrast to
what happens with many boys who have
read syndrome clinically the males in
this of this mouse model they do survive
they develop symptoms about eight weeks
of age but they die shortly thereafter
and females will develop symptoms at 20
weeks they do have several
characteristic symptoms that mimic the
symptoms of red syndrome that you see in
the clinical population
these include tremor abnormal gait
pattern and seizures apneas and hind
limb clasping which you can see here on
the right if you pick a wild-type mouse
up by the tail
they will splay their back legs out
however if you pick up a mutant male in
this case mecp2 back out they will
involuntarily knuckle their back legs in
and one of the things I think that's
really encouraging about Rhett syndrome
in an area that is enticing a lot of
interest in coming up with therapeutics
or a treatment for this disorder is that
the symptoms can be reversed in mice
if mecp2 is restored in neurons post
development and so that suggests that
Rhett syndrome is not a
neurodegenerative disorder but it is a
obviously a neurological
neurodevelopmental disorder but that may
be it could be reversed post development
by various treatment strategies so we
got into studying Rett syndrome
by thinking about where some of the
targets in the vicinity were expressed
within the brain sort of capitalizing on
programs that we had ongoing already and
so what I'm going to show you next these
are data from the hippocampus which is
critical for learning and memory and it
had been previously published that
hippocampal synapses exhibit impairments
in mecp2 leading mice and so what we're
going to be doing here is
electrophysiological recordings the
Schaffer collaterals and hippocampus
project to the ca1 region and so we're
going to stimulate the Schaffer
collaterals and we're going to record
from cells in the ca1 region of the
hippocampus and so what you see these
are data that we replicated in-house
that hadn't previously published and so
what we're looking at our hippocampal
Schaffer collaterals ca1 synapses so as
cca1 synapses and what you see on the
left these are called field excitatory
postsynaptic potentials slopes so what
we're doing is we're measuring the slope
of the line where it says under stimulus
1 we're measuring the slope of that line
and we're comparing wild-type animals
versus mecp2 mutants and you can see
that the mutants have a large increase
in the field
EPS v slope over a large range of signal
intensities if you then compare the
slope of two pulses administered a
certain period of time apart you can see
that in wild-type animals you see if you
take the ratio of slope 1 just look -
you have a pair of pulse ratio of
approximately - shown in the black
symbols in the mecp2 mutants you see
that you have a slope of approximately 1
indicating that those two slopes are
equal this is indicative it's not
conclusive but it's indicative of some
type of presynaptic change in
neurotransmitter release and then if you
actually perform experiments looking at
long-term potentiation at these synapses
so in this case we're taking a baseline
read and then we're stimulating with two
times 100 Hertz stimulation in the
wild-type animals in black you can see
that we induce a long-term potentiation
just seeing out it's 50 to 60 minute
time period
but in the mecp2 mutant animals we don't
see LTP induction at these synapses and
so overall to us these data fit was some
type of altered expression or function
of a presynaptic regulator of
neurotransmitter release
and so we honed in on tablature by
glutamate receptor 7 and we seven for
several reasons so we knew that Embu 7
was involved in neurotransmitter release
as many of the N blue receptors harmed
it's highly expressed in the active
zones of glutamate and GABA urging
synapses and it is the only presynaptic
at a vector by glutamate receptor
expressed at FCC a 1 synapses in adult
animals which is the time period that
we're recording and with seven
stimulation inhibits glutamate and GABA
release and we have shown that mv7
activation was absolutely required for
the induction of long-term potentiation
LTP in the campus and a previous study
that was done looking at G R + 7 - the
gene that encodes Embu 7 in cancer
patients had shown that the G m7
promoter was controlled by methylation
and the gene obviously that's mutated in
Rett syndrome is a methyl binding
protein so this suggested the following
hypothesis that gr m7 is an
epigenetically regulated gene that's
involved in modulating their on
transmission so could this be a
candidate for regulation by Becky - and
so we built a reporter construct in
which we had either a minimal reporter
of stream of allusive raised expression
vector or we had the GR m7 promoter
about a thousand base pairs of that
driving luciferase expression and we
transfected these into cells what we
found is that if we Co expressed either
the minimal promoter with Beck v2 we did
not see a significant increase in
transcription or production of
luciferase however with the gr m7
promoter driving to freeze production we
did see an increase over the minimal
promoter alone and also a concentration
dependent increase when we increase the
level of expression of meki - so this
suggests that men key to activate
human gm7 expression in vitro so our
prediction was that M the seven levels
would be decreased in human read
patience and an MHC b2 deficient mice so
we were lucky enough to partner with
Rett syndrome org and also the NIH brain
Bank to obtain samples from patients
autopsy samples from patients who had
died who had read syndrome and so what
we're looking at here in the upper left
hand corner we're looking at gr m7
messenger RNA and you see in this small
sample set we did not see this did not
reach statistical significance however
if we looked at the mv7 protein levels
we saw a highly significant decrease in
my seven expression this is in the
cortex we also saw this in the
cerebellum in contrast if we use a
control so a particular glutamate
receptor transporter protein we don't
see a significant decrease here and at
the bottom you just were showing the
western blotting and then the specific
mutations each of these patients have so
then we moved into our mouse model to
see if we could replicate that mu seven
levels were deficient and then use
allosteric modulator z' to manipulate
the activity of feo seven potentially
for therapeutic benefit and so what
you're looking at and slide on the left
this is looking at the cortex in the
hippocampus these are synaptic zone
preparations so we're looking at mv7
expression at some incent atoms at the
synapse and you see that we saw a
significant decrease in m7 expression in
the hippocampus we then moved into our
electrophysiological studies looking at
LTP and what we're looking at here in
the black this again is the same LTP
paradigm I showed before
these are wild-type mice in black the
mecp2 deficient in this case these are
females are shown in red you see they
have a deficiency in LTP however if we
pretreat the slices for ten minutes
prior to inducing LTP we can completely
rescue the LTP deficit with a positive
allosteric modulator that has activity
at MV seven and this is quantified in
the graph on the far right
for the last 10-15 minutes of recording
we also observed these effects using a
structurally distinct positive
allosteric modulator again suggesting
that this is m27 that we are modulating
and that pans can have efficacy in this
model so in an LTP paradigm we're
releasing large amounts of glutamate and
the seven has low affinity for glutamate
by the presence of a Pam we can get
potentiation we also show that the
rescue of LTP is similar in male
complete knockout animals and so then we
ask the question will reversal of LTP
deficits translate to behavioral
paradigms
so the first assay we looked at this is
a conditioned fear paradigm and what
we're doing here is we're placing the
mice allowing them to bitchu ate for a
certain period of time in a box and then
we give the mice a mild flip shock this
is aversive to mice and when you put
them back in the box the next day
they'll remember that the last time they
were in that box they received a shock
and so they'll freeze and so something
that had been known in the literature
that we replicated here was that in
black we're looking at wild-type animals
and then in red these are the
heterozygous female any cd2 mutants and
you see that the mecp2 mutants have a
deficiency in the freezing response
suggesting that they don't remember that
that box was aversive to them the
previous day if we treat them with a
dose of our positive allosteric
modulator bu 0 4 2 2 2 8 8 and we're
giving this on the day of training so
the day that we should shock them you
see that we put them back in the box the
next day now they have remembered that
that box was aversive vu 288 is not
completely selective for M blue 7 among
all the temperature of glutamate
receptors it's selective among between
Group 1 and 2 and group 3 so M blue 7 is
one of the groups free miss rabbit over
glutamate receptors and bu 288 is a
positive allosteric modulator of M
before and blue 7 and then blue eight we
then used a compound called a TX eight
eight one seven eight which is a Pam of
before and mb8 but has no activity at
m27 and so we use this compound we see
that we do not see a rescue of the
freezing behavior consistent with this
effect being mediated by potentiation of
m7 condition fear is a obviously it's a
fear-based paradigm so we wanted to ask
the question in another model of
cognition would we also see a benefit of
our Pam the you to 8/8 and so this is a
novel object recognition task and so
we're placing the mice into a box with
two identical objects initially and then
in the second phase of the task we come
back and place one novel object and one
familiar object in the box and a normal
Mouse a wild-type Mouse shown in black
will prefer to explore the novel object
and this can be plotted as a
discrimination index where mice
preferring the novel object will be
positive my preferring the familiar
object will be negative and mice that
have no preference will be in the middle
and you can see that the mecp2 mutants
have no preference in this task however
again if we treat them eyes with the u28
we can completely rescue this effect and
this is not observed with our control
allosteric modulator with only activity
at M before and F of 8 we performed an
additional a say this is looking at
anxiety so this is an elevated plus maze
mice don't like to be this has four arms
and two were closed and two are open
mice generally do not like to be in the
open arms because they feel that's
threatening and so they tend to stay in
the closed arms of the elevated plus
maze and so in this experiment the
wild-type mice spent about 30 percent of
their time the open arms
the mecp2 deficient mice consistent with
the literature actually have sort of an
anxiolytic effect here in which they'll
spend more time in the open arms we were
able to reverse this using bu two eight
eight but interestingly we also saw an
effect with our control compound
suggesting that this effect may not be
mv7 deviated an additional task we did
looks at something called social
recognition
and it's you know you never you don't
want to anthropomorphize too much about
my interaction with other mice
reflecting humans interaction with other
humans since it's kind of an interesting
task in which the mouse is placed into
the center of a three chambered box and
then on one side of the Box we place an
empty wire cup on the other side you
have the wire Cup with a mouse under it
most mice will perform prefer to spend
time with a mouse versus an inanimate
object and then in the next phase of the
task you put the familiar mouse the
mouse at the map that the test mouse is
already seen on one side and then the
other side you add a new mouse a mouse
that the year test Mouse has never seen
before and most mice will prefer to
spend time with the new Mouse than the
new stranger and so what you're looking
at here this is a comparison on the left
of wild type animal responses and then
on the right these are the mecp2
heterozygous animals and so what you see
on the far left
if you treat mice with vehicle in their
wild-type animals they will prefer to
spend time with stranger - so the new
Mouse but they haven't seen before if
you give you to a date or our control
compound 80 X you see that there's no
change in this preference in the mecp2
mutants however they do not have a
preference for stranger - versus
stranger one however again if you treat
them with vu - a date now this
preference becomes apparent and if you
treat them with the control compound you
do not replicate this effect this
suggests that this is an EM boo 78 in
effect also when we submitted these data
for publication was it was requested
that we repeat all these studies these
studies that you're seeing right here
these were done with a single dose of
compound but obviously read is a
lifelong disorder and so we were asked
to do a more chronic dosing paradigm and
so we developed a phenotyping scheduled
will reduce the compound over multiple
days and we still sought significant
advocacy in all the tasks that I've
shown you after dosing the mice for two
math weeks something that I'm really
excited about and that we we think about
a lot in the vicinity when we're trying
to develop new compounds for GPCRs
is objective biomarkers so models of
cognition and social interaction can be
very difficult to assess particularly in
in a clinical trial with patients who
may not be able to talk and so we ask
the question so as I mentioned ret
patients have apneas and this is
faithfully recapitulated in the animals
and what you're looking at it upon the
top left this is a replace the animals
inside a apparatus called a whole-body
plasma graft
this measures various parameters of
breathing and inspiration exploration
etc as you see the normal pattern of a
wild-type animal in the upper left-hand
corner on the bottom what you see this
is an mecp2 deficient female Mouse and
as I mentioned there's these periods of
hyperventilation and then an apnea so
the line gets flat suggesting that the
mice are not breathing if we dose with
the you to 8/8 we can completely correct
this effect we do not see correction of
this using our control modulator that
doesn't have activity at m27 and so
these various parameters here that
you're seeing on the right frequency
time inspiration time expiration you can
see that on some of these parameters we
are seeing effects of both 2 8 8 and the
Attucks compound and these actually
could be potentially interpreted as
negative if you're having effects on
inspiration and expiration in addition
to effects on apneas and so what you see
in the bottom panel panel D these are
the actual quantitation of the apneas
between either wild-type and black or
the mecp2 mutants you see that there's a
large increase in apneas that's
completely reversed with the u2 a date
and it's not reversed with the control
Pam but this advocates for higher for
compounds with better selectivity for
Embu 7 to test the hypothesis that the
effects of an on apneas will be observed
without effects on inspiration
expiration which could be negative but
again this represents a very objective
biomarker that could be used in a
clinical study to look at efficacy of an
allosteric modulator of n-woo 7 so for
this first part of the talk
what I've shown you is some of the
advantages potentially for allosteric
modulator z' but in the case of breast
syndrome using this is a case study
deficits in synaptic transmission LTP
point to the involvement of a
presynaptic metabotropic glutamate
receptor in mecp2 deficient lies mo7
protein levels are significantly reduced
in female rat patients and red model ice
and potentiation of m27 using small
molecule cams can rescue synaptic
plasticity and behavioral deficits in
mecp2 deficient animals including at
meals these studies included chronic
dosing and as I mentioned apnea is our
translational and objective biomarker
that can be used clinically to sentenced
so one question we always get asked
about this project is if Emma 7 is
important in red syndrome then why don't
mice that don't have and with 7 sodium 7
knockout mice at red syndrome and
actually we've begun a phenotyping study
here where we are observing several
behaviors that we see in Jairam 7th
knockout mice that are similar to mecp2
heterozygous or mutant camels these are
things like the elevated plus maze as I
mentioned the mecp2 deficient mice will
spend more time in the open arms we also
see that in mice that lack and the 7 and
also contextual fear conditioning if you
remember the mecp2 deficient mice did
not freeze as much we place them back in
the box
the next day we see the same thing with
a Jairam 7 knockout animals and so one
of the really interesting thing about
having these phenotypes to look at me
size is it provides us with an animal
model to test the selectivity of the
allosteric modulator that we are
identifying and so obviously we would we
would expect that we would not see
efficacy of the compound in contextual
fear conditioning in the Nambu 7
knockout animal we might see activity in
elevated plus maze if we're actually
activating em before or Embu 8 as was
shown with our Attucks compound so those
studies are underway
jerem 7 knockout mice also exhibit
impairments in social interaction that
mimic will be saw in mecp2 division
lines
something an interesting study that we
did is we asked the question if we over
trained the ANBU 7 knockout mice or grm
7 knockouts would they eventually learn
the memory so if we gave them multiple
sessions of in this case shock would
they eventually be able to learn the
task and so what you're seeing on the
left this is the overtraining paradigm
in which we're giving them multiple
exposures and you can see that over time
the Jairam 7 knockout mice will learn to
be able to do this task so then if we
come back the next day and ask do they
remember the task you can see with this
overtraining paradigm that they do after
one hour they are able to remember this
and after 24 hours this difference is
not statistically significant however
what was really interesting if you keep
putting my SPAC in the box day after day
after day eventually wild-type animals
will learn that that box is not
dangerous anymore and they will
extinguish that memory and so what you
see interestingly with the wild-type
mice in black is you see that eventually
they will learn the box to no longer
aversive and they will stop freezing
however the gm7 knockout mice will
continue to freeze if you keep putting
them back in the box
and so this is a really interesting
phenotype in the context potentially of
a post-traumatic stress disorder type
model and so we're investigating this in
more detail interestingly and jairam 7
knockout mice do show a clasping
phenotype that is very similar to what
you see in the NBC b to count animals I
would point out that there are lots of
mouse models that do show clasping
phenotype we just found that this is
interesting and it actually appears very
early in the gerund 7 knockouts and we
can actually genotype the mice by this
this classic phenotype very very early
in addition you can't really see it here
but the Jairam 7 knockout mice also
robustly class not only their hind legs
but also their portland's and so this is
something that's really interesting and
suggestive of an earlier phenotype
additionally the Jairam 7 knockout mice
as I mentioned
many retsina patients will have seizures
that are difficult to treat and so this
is using surface EEG recordings then
you're seeing on the left this is a
seizure that is happening in a gm7
knockout mouse and if we then isolate
brain regions from mice either that are
well type from Jairam seven not got my
setup not had a seizure or grm seven
knockout mice that have had a seizure
you see that you see a large increase in
immediate early gene expression so in
this case see fossa expression in the
hippocampus and so we think the
hippocampus is involved in mediating
these seizures in these animals and so
right now we're doing a systematic
comparison of what the seizures look
like in endurance have a knockout animal
versus an mecp2 heterozygous for back
out Mouse so we do see a phenocopy of a
number of phenotypes between 0 and 7
knockouts and mbcp two heterozygous or
knockout mice and as I mentioned this
will be really important for continuing
to validate that
Embu 7 is the target that we want to be
modulating via 2 8 8 was an early
compound that we developed here at
Vanderbilt we currently do have a lead
optimization campaign ongoing try to
develop compounds with better
selectivity a friend who 7 to continue
to validate that that is the target we
want to modulate in this disorder and so
you see that in Jairam 7 knockout mice
versus mecp2 head or not have animals
that there are this large range of
phenotypes anxiety contextual fear
social interaction hind limb clasping
grip strength some of these I didn't
have time to show you but rotor odd and
seizures that are common between the two
disorders we don't see apnea in the
Jairam 7da so we thought very very early
on that there could be a phenotype of
apneas but with additional studies we do
not see a deficit in Apia we also don't
see a deficit in novel object
recognition but coming back to the
points in the middle we know that these
top three are reversed five uj8 and so
we're testing these other phenotypes in
the mecp2 mutants to see if we can
reverse this with two eight eight and
also to use the knockouts to show that
the effect is mediated by a blue 7
so another question that we thought we
were in a good position to ask was if
mv7 is regulated by mecp2 will nb7
signal and be inversely affected if
mecp2 is overexpressed and the reason
this is important clinically is because
of another disorder that's called mecp2
duplication syndrome and this was
identified both Rhett syndrome and
duplication syndrome were identified by
Doctor Who zombie at Baylor and she had
asked the question if she over expressed
any cb2 in the context of a mouse that
lacked mecp2 could she reversed the
phenotypes and she could but the mice
that had an mecp2 duplication or in some
cases even higher expression of mecp2
also clete had clear phenotypes and so
that led her to identify to seek out
whether there were patients who might
have an mecp2 duplication and she did
identify this is a true syndrome it
occurs most of the time in voice and
it's caused by duplication or
triplication of the portion of the X
chromosome that contains mecp2
and the duplication or triplication is
usually inherited from the mother and so
therefore it's most severe in voice
since they only have one X chromosome
and as girls have to in some cell types
because of random X chromosome
inactivation B in both the context of
red and duplication each patient
expresses a certain a different
percentage potentially of the wild-type
X chromosome or the mutant X chromosome
and so the symptoms of duplication
syndrome are hypotonia poor motor
development recurrent respiratory
infections which can be very
debilitating intellectual disability
little to no speech features of autism
and seizures and so we had the
hypothesis that potentially mb7 could be
involved in both of these disorders and
some of that came from data that had
been in the literature that we
replicated in-house we're looking again
these are electrophysiological studies
looking at the SCCA 1 synapses and
comparing Rhett syndrome and duplication
syndrome MDS model lives
so as I showed you before these data are
in a slightly different format on the
right we're looking at field excitatory
postsynaptic potential slopes and you
see that in the MACD to mutants we have
an increase compared to wild-type and
the paired pulse ratio is deficient in
the mecp2
mutants as shown in the black on the
upper right in contrast in mecp2
overexpressing lights you see the exact
opposite so on the bottom panel in C the
field epsp slopes in the mice that
overexpress MACD to looser mecp2 tg1
mice are lower than wall type and the
paired pulse ratio goes in the opposite
direction
it's actually higher than in wild-type
animals so it had been known in
literature that mice that have a
duplication or are transgenic lee
expressing excess MFP to exhibit
deficits in fear conditioning and
extinction to this again are measures of
money in memory and so these data on the
top right or from this paper that i've
referenced from lisa montages lab and
what you're looking at again this is a
fear conditioning paradigm comparing
wild-type or in this case this is mecp2
being expressed only in neurons and what
you see is in the wild types as i
mentioned if you do the fear
conditioning paradigm and then keep
putting them back in the box
eventually they will extinguish that
behavior in contrast the mice over
expressing MHC 2 have this long lasting
deficit in extinction which is pretty
it's pretty robust and profound and
we've been able to replicate that here
looking at either contextual fear at
24-hour time point or over the
extinction paradigm with the duplication
mice shown in red and so we ask the
question we have the hypothesis that
this looks like the opposite of what we
see in red syndrome in terms of
hippocampal phenotypes and synaptic
plasticity so will genetic reduction of
m27 or an MV 7 negative allosteric
modulator in this case reverse these
deficits and so unfortunately that did
not happen and so what you're looking at
in this slide this is genetic reduction
so we've crossed the mice over
expressing MHC V 2 with mice that
one allele of emphasis so heterozygous
for m27 and we're looking at just the
expression of an mu seven to make sure
that we had decreased it in the MACD to
transgenic background and so what you
see is we do have approximately fifty
percent of lung expression level of zero
and seven both in the Jairam set of
heterozygous mice in that heterozygous
mice that are also transgenic for mecp2
and what we found is when we did the
fear extinction paradigm in wild-type or
the jerem seven head shown in this green
color you see that they do extinguish
their behavior but then regardless of
and with seven expression the transgenic
mice do not extinguish the sphere
behavior and that's just shown
quantified here on sorry on the bottom
this is again this elevated plus maze
and we're looking at between well type
in mecp2 transgenic the transgenics have
decreased time of the open arms sit of
what we see in the rest of our model
mice and we were not able to impact this
by decreasing expression event was
heaven and interestingly what we found
was that english said an antagonism
actually impairs extinction in wild-type
mice that's shown here in this graph
we're looking at wild-type or any CP
transgenics which have as I mentioned on
the previous slide they have increased
freezing behavior we were not able to
impact this with a negative allosteric
modulator of n-woo seven this is another
addicts compound called a TX seven one
seven forty three and so in the blue
bars you see that we're not able to
change the effect in the NB C to
transgenics consistent with our genetic
study in contrast in the wild-type
animals in white we did see an increase
in contextual fear freezing suggesting
that antagonism of the seven cause
retention of that memory and when we did
these studies we decided to use our
positive allosteric modulator of the
group 3 and temperature pollutant
receptors to eight eight we used for all
our red studies and what we're able to
show is that in the blue bars we were
able to get a suit
introduction in fear behavior and we
were not able to see this with our
control compound that doesn't potentiate
epicenter and to show that this was not
a fluke in one particular assay we also
saw the same pharmacology using elevated
plus maze so in wild types in red versus
transcendence in blue we saw a decreased
time of the open arms of the transgenics
this was not impacted using an Ambu 7
selective negative allosteric modulator
it was reversed using a Pam and we did
not see a significant result with our
adex control compound that only
potentiates endless war and eight so
this is really interesting because it's
suggesting that the same mode of
pharmacology is affecting phenotypes in
models of both red in which mecp2 is
well and duplication syndrome which is
high and it's interesting if you compare
sort of the we're calling the yin and
yang of ret and duplication syndrome
there are many phenotypes that are
opposite microcephaly matress effli
grossly opposite between these two
disorders are not shared between the two
disorders but in the middle of this Venn
diagram you see that there are many
phenotypes that are shared and whether
they have the same molecular
underpinnings or whether they're there
different between the different
disorders is still to be worked out but
it's sort of interesting that there's
this intersection of phenotypes here in
the middle and a paper that was just
published by who does on these lab a
really interesting paper looking at the
hippocampus in mice that either are
lacking mu c b2 or that have over
expression of obesity to show that in
both of those models you get synchrony
within the hippocampus that looks very
similar there are some differences
between the models but in general it
looks like there's some type of shared
synaptic plasticity or connectivity
deficit between the two disorders and so
we postulate that potentially and the
seven could be involved that the nexus
of these different disorders that's
something we're working on them
within the last couple years it's been
really exciting to see that there are
now primary mutations in gr m7 and this
is happening because more and more
patients who have a neurodevelopmental
disorder are undergoing whole exome
sequencing and so what's now been
identified is that there are primary
mutations in G R and 7 in patients with
undiagnosed neurodevelopmental disorders
and so some of these examples are shown
here in which there been two brothers
that are reported or homozygous for a
mutation in what we call the Venus
flytrap domain of the n blues for the
large extracellular domain that binds
glutamate and these brothers share
developmental delay seizures atrophy
thin corpus callosum etc and also
hypotonia which mimics what you see in
duplication syndrome in another case our
our brother and sister and they are
compound heterozygous they've shown in
the picture here in the middle they are
compound heterozygous they have one
mutation on each copy of Jairam seven
that correspond to transmembrane domain
3 in the G protein-coupled receptor and
they have developmental delay have todya
intellectual disability seizures and
then this paper recently by Reuter at
all two cousins who are homozygous for a
truncation mutation and they are listed
as exhibiting profound intellectual
disability seizures recurrent infections
etc and so we're now preparing these
different mutants and testing them for
function and sensitivity to allosteric
modulator x' I want to wrap up for a
last few minutes with a new study that
we've undertaken here at Vanderbilt
trying to widen the types of indications
for which mb7 modulator z' may be useful
or important and so this is based on
studies at Vanderbilt so any patient
that comes to Vanderbilt who agrees to
give their DNA and their medical record
becomes part of what's called bio vu
bioview and so the patient comes in
their DNA may be sequence and their
medical record is given an
identification code and de-identified so
they
can't be linked to that specific patient
and the information is stored in the bio
feed database and what the folks at the
Vanderbilt Institute for clinical and
translational research did for us is
they said are there snips in genes of
interest to the BC entity or that can be
are there in a target that might be
repurposed for a specific drug
indication that can open up new avenues
for new disorders that might respond to
modulators that we are developing here
at BC entity and so they did this for
gm7 and one of these associations that
came out was neurofibromatosis the nerve
our mitosis type 1 is an autosomal
dominant disorder and it's caused by
mutations in the neurofibroma gene
interestingly I mean we're not cancer
biologists and so when this came up as a
potential link to germ 7 we dug into the
literature we found that about 65% of
nf1 patients are diagnosed with a
learning disability and about 25% of the
patients also have an autism spectrum
disorder what you see on the right these
are some of the characteristic symptoms
in there a fiber test to type one so
brown spots on the skin bone defects
scoliosis neurofibromas which many most
cases are benign but can be painful and
figuring Lisch nodules which are
markings on the iris of the eye and in
some cases optic glioma
and so where are these snips that are
associated with neurofibromatosis and
there were two of them where are they
located in the Jairam 7 gene they are
located very close together they're in
the intron between exon 7 & 8 one of
them is predicted to be a binding site
for a transcription factor called PE a3
and the minor allele is predicted to
lose PE a3 binding the other is
predicted to be a binding site for p53
which is a tumor suppressor which is
interesting in the context of
neurofibromatosis as these patients have
benign tumors and if you have the minor
allele is predicted to have a loss of
p53 binding so we looked at the allele
frequency and disease prevalence across
different populations of these two cents
what we found is that there is
differential expression of the alleles
in different populations so for example
on for the first snip here on the left
in the North American population you can
see the distribution here and the minor
allele is expressed as present to lower
extent than you see the other alleles
however in North African each Asian
individuals you see that you have an
increased prevalence of the minor allele
and you also see some divergence with
the other snip as well what's
interesting about this is that the
prevalence of nf1 in the North American
population is about one in 5,000 whereas
in the North African of East Asian
populations it's about one in 1,000
which suggests that maybe the alleles at
Jairam said that have something to do
with manifestation of neurofibromatosis
and so we got interested in looking at
similarities between mice that lack
neurofibroma with mice that model Rhett
syndrome because it had on the on the
left here what you've seen these is this
is our data in which we are looking at a
Rhett syndrome model looking at wild
type or mecp2 deficient mice and
rescuing the LTP deficit with our
positive allosteric modulator and when
I've been reported in the literature is
that in mice that lack neurofibroma you
see that they have actually also a
deficit in long-term potentiation and so
we're asking the question will
potentiation of Embu 7 lead to reversal
of these phenotypes in it in the mouse
model of neurofibromatosis as well as
Rhett syndrome so the deficits in the
nf1 knockout mice are consistent with a
presynaptic decrease in gaba release and
the results that mention overlap with
our studies in regulation of gaba
release in LTP by mu 7 in appearance in
red model mice and so these are really
preliminary data but we're excited about
this so we're using our bu to 8:8
allosteric modulator and this is again
is the condition contextual fear
paradigm in wild-type in black and if
one heterozygous mice and beret and nf1
knockouts in
and you see that if you treat these mice
with vehicle much like what we see with
the Rhett syndrome ice we see a deficit
and freezing behavior in the nf1
knockout animals and this can be rescued
if we give to a day before training
so in conclusion and with seven protein
levels are simply regulated by MEC b2
and are reduced and female where a
patient's germ 7 that kept mice
phenocopy
mice that lack mecp2 and unexpectedly a
Pam corrects phenotypic deficits in
mecp2 duplication syndrome and what I
had here is improved safety profile and
the reason I have this here is that one
of the major strategies that's being
pursued for Rhett syndrome treatment is
to use gene therapy to increase mecp2
expression and so that's an it's an
interesting strategy because of
duplication syndrome it may be difficult
to get exactly the right dose of gene
therapy to induce efficacy but it would
suggest that if a patient was taking an
Ambu 7 pan and underwent gene therapy
that maybe that would be a safe
combination versus a pan exacerbating in
effect when you have increased mecp2
expression new neurodevelopmental
disorders are being linked to the June
17 and potentiation of Embu 7 corrects
and Pierre Curie responses in nf1
animals and so I just want to end here
by sort of a discussion about allosteric
ligands so we're developing new Embu 7
pans and Nan's to continue to validate
Embu 7 as a target neurodevelopmental
disorders and when I have here potential
pet ligand so positive allosteric
modulator x' are very difficult to
develop as a pet tracer so why do you
want to pet tracer well if you're going
to go into a clinical study you need to
know if you don't see any efficacy
did you actually test your hypothesis
did the drug get to where it needed to
be and one way to do that is to develop
a positron emission tomography ligand
that you can then displace with your
work drug and you can use that to set
dosed in the clinic but it's very very
difficult to develop a pet ligand for a
positive
modulator and it has to do with the way
pans work they might be very very potent
in vitro their potency comes from a
combination of their affinity at the
receptor but also their ability to be
cooperative with the endogenous ligand
so they either increase the affinity of
the endogenous ligand ie glutamate or
they can increase the coupling or the
signaling downstream of Ebla 7 and so a
lot of times pans are actually very low
affinity by themselves they have to have
the agonist there in order to induce
their response and if you have different
different amounts of glutamate
throughout the brain you can get
differences in your label and look up at
tracer negative allosteric modulator in
general have a much better correlation
between their in vitro potency and their
in vitro affinity and so you can it may
be easier to develop a very high
affinity ligand which is what you need
to have in order to have a BAC tracer
and so we're developing these compounds
in parallel so that we can have the
potential of developing a pet library
and that might be a name that we could
then displace with a positive allosteric
modulator additionally if we did have a
pet ligand we could survey throughout
the brain of a patient with red or a
patient with duplication to see do they
have a deficit for example in right
syndrome do they have a deficit in n7
expressions everywhere in the brain or
are there certain areas where mb7
expression is not impacted and could
that lead to change the nepeta see of a
compound or a change in safety profile
so thank you very much for listening to
my presentation obviously this is the
Vanderbilt Center for Neuroscience drug
discovery is a large integrated group of
individuals led by at the bottom of this
slide
Jeff Kahn Craig Lindsley Gary Jones and
then David sweat is our chair of
pharmacology at be sanity in addition we
have developed what we call team mecp2
within the Center for Neuroscience drug
discovery and in particular rocket lab
lady Nicole Fisher Becca Center brain
and stands Lee have been instrumental to
the work that I've shown you today in
addition to the basic science work that
we're doing obviously with a large group
that's focused
probe development and looking at
optimizing small molecules for starting
with - screening than through medicinal
chemistry and drug metabolism to
identify tool compounds that are
absolutely critical to the ability to
identify new targets or new indications
for areas that we're working in our
collaboration with Victor Van de Velde
Institute for clinical and translational
research was instrumental in getting us
into the area of nf1 which were excited
about and also our funding from Brett
Sandberg Autism Speaks and I made a
congressionally directed medical
research program grants and and cats
award and now I'm happy to take any
questions thank you doctor my slender
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's get started our first question is
do you think patients with all specific
point mutations will respond similarly
to M blue 7 Pam's and will M through 7
Pam's work for red syndrome patients
without without a mecp2 mutation thanks
that's a great question
so this is an area that we are exploring
more and more carefully now so the mice
that we've used are actually a knockout
of the macb tube gene and in the male's
is a complete knockout in the females
this is a heterozygote and this is very
different from what you see in most
patients who have red syndrome who might
have a point mutation somewhere in the
macd - gene and we don't yet understand
how those different point mutations
first of all affect mecp2 stability how
do they interact with whether they
change transcriptional regulation
induced by mecp2
and so it's an important question to ask
will
vii Pam's work equally well in all
different types of Rhett syndrome or all
different types of mutations so we're
looking at different mice that have very
specific point mutations to see if we
still see efficacy the point about
different patients not having a mutation
in mecp2 as I mentioned red syndrome is
clinically diagnosed and then the
patient's DNA is sequence to try to
fight or figure out where the mutation
is and there are some patients that
don't have a mutation in mecp2 but they
are diagnosed as Rhett syndrome and so
in general those patients have a
mutation in another gene and the most
common genes for that are Fox g1 or
something called CB kl5 and so we
anticipate that because we are targeting
shared symptoms between these disorders
that an N mu 7 pam that has an effect in
a Rhett syndrome phenotype that's shared
and these other disorders may have the
potential to have advocacy for those
patients and so we're excited about
testing some of those hypotheses by
using mouse models of those other
disorders our next question is do you
think M glue 7 expression will be
decreased in every area of the RET brain
do you have plans to test this yeah this
is a great this is a great question and
something we're thinking about all the
time and it goes back to the discussion
about if we had a pet ligand that we
might be able to go and address this
question but I think that's something
else it's important to think about here
as I mentioned red syndrome is a
progressive disorder so it's changing
over time and so do and with seven
expression levels change during the
course of the disease I think that
that's really interesting and could
impact the type of pharmacology that we
might want to modulate if Embu 7 is not
low during the Russian phase we may not
want to treat patients with an onset of
ham during that phase that disease so
that's something that hopefully if we
can optimize a good pet tracer we can
really start to ask this those questions
our next question is what do you think
is the mechanism by which M blue 7 pans
appear to reverse deficits in both
models of red and mecp2 duplication
syndrome yeah this is a
is a great question this is sort of
where we're heading we have some ideas
about this the fact that who does obvi
slab has published that there may be
shared circuitry and hippocampus is the
area that we're focusing on now and so
we're looking for something that we have
noticed in our studies originally we
thought that n was 7 was going to be the
Jairam 7 gene was going to be the target
of mecp2
and that it was going to be a direct
target what we're seeing as we're
looking across different regions of the
brain is we're having an RNA protein
disconnect and so we're trying to figure
out first of all what is the mechanism
by which mecp2 really regulates n-woo 7
in this case protein expression we
always see the protein is very low but
the RNA sometimes it's not and so we're
thinking about things like anti sense
strategies or thinking that maybe mecp2
is modulating something that interacts
with and with 7 but maybe not Andrew 7
itself and maybe it keeps Emma 7 on the
surface of a neuron or increases protein
stability etc so those are all active
questions that we're trying to ask but
we think it's really interesting the
same mode of pharmacology is impacting
both of these disease models this
suggests that maybe there are shared
symptoms between these two disorders
that could both be treated using the
same pharmacological strategy our next
question is how does this approach
compared with mecp2 replacement
strategies right so there is a big
movement right now to try to get at the
root cause of read syndrome absolutely
is the deficit in mecp2 and so
theoretically if you could fix that
deficit then you could have the greatest
impact for Rett syndrome I think we're
we're positioning ourselves is using
Rett syndrome as a model to first of all
be able to understand the basic biology
event the seventh and the therapeutic
potential not only for Rett syndrome but
for other disorders as well so if we can
for example find utility for M blue 7
Pam's and reversing seizures then maybe
we can extrapolate that to other
disorders where seizures are present
where you might not see efficacy of
mecp2 gene replacement - might work
well for Rhett and maybe not for another
disease that has seizures and so we're
sort of looking at this as a model
system that we could potentially have an
impact in therapeutically but also to
allow us to branch out into other other
disorders and it looks like we have time
for one more question do you think that
the polymorphism with a gr m7 gene that
is predicted to alter p53 binding
contributes to the tumors in nf1
patients yeah this is something that
we've been talking a lot with our
colleagues in the translational Center
here as I mentioned you know we're not
really a tumor biologist here in the BCD
but I think that this this interaction
is too is too strong to ignore so we are
we're actively thinking about how
altering that binding might contribute
to tumors and so we're going to start
developing collaborations to look at a
mu 7 expression and p53 expression in
tumors from nf1 page primary tumors from
nf1 patients so I think it's a really
interesting interesting possibility that
regulation of GR m7 somehow contributes
to cancer development it's an area that
we hadn't really thought about before so
we're excited about it I would like to
once again thank dr. nice weather for
her presentation I'd also like to thank
Ladbrokes for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2018
you will receive an email from laberd's
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with their colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye